the typing rebellions or an attempt by
Chinese Rebels to overthrow the Imperial
government there and replace it with a
semi-christian Theocratic State this
came during a time of high tensions and
great distrust between the Chinese
government and the Western powers in
spite of this distrust and also the fact
that the Western powers and the rebels
shared a religion the Europeans and
Americans sided against the rebels which
raises the question why why did the
Christian westerners fight against the
Christian Rebels during the typing
Rebellion so in 1850 in order to clamp
down on religious dissent the central
Chinese government opted to purge
Christians across the country these
purges were mostly aimed at the growing
group of Christians called The Society
of God worshipers this soon led to
violence after which the god worshipers
were in open Rebellion these Christians
were led by a man called hongju Tuan and
he was determined to establish a new
China the Heavenly Kingdom of Great
peace which he would do by force at
first like most rebellions in China the
Western Powers just ignored it but as
the influence of the taiping rebels grew
and they took more and more territory
they had to choose the side one way or
the other Hong was quick to reach out to
the Western power since he believed that
they were brothers in arms against the
mysticism of the Chinese emperor the
Americans had quite a high opinion of
him and the US government made
preparations for recognizing taiping
Independence as well as what to do with
Hong successfully replaced the emperor
that said there was nothing formal put
into action since they wanted to see
what the British would do as the
foreigners with the most influence in
China and the British said no to helping
Hong and not long afterwards so did the
French so why well there were two main
reasons the first was money britinda
just won a lot of trade concessions in
Hong Kong as a result of the first Opium
War and whilst the Qing government was
bound to respect those concessions under
the threat of force the taiping were not
and irrespective of how friendly Hong
had presented himself the British didn't
want to support an unknown quantity
furthermore there was a lot of distrust
of the rebels in their aims when the
taiping captured territory a lot of
murder tended to happen which soured
Britain and France's opinions of the
rebels and the second reason why the
Christian West didn't support the
taiping rebels was religion now whilst
Tong was not nominally a Protestant he
and his followers interpretation of
Christianity was seen as offensive
because Hong not only considered himself
to be the rightful king of China but
also the literal younger brother of
Jesus Christ this claim of Hong being
the holy bro alongside the mixing of
Christian doctrine with traditional
Chinese religious beliefs meant that
most Christians didn't see the typing
Rebels as fellow Believers and so
Britain and France opted to support the
Qing Emperor to stop this new
unpredictable group from taking power
and potentially ruining the money-making
opportunities that they had and with
Britain and France supporting the
central government the Americans felt
that there was little to be gained from
helping the taiping and so the rebellion
was left to its fate which in case
you're wondering was death I hope you
enjoyed this episode with a special
thanks to my patrons James bizonette
Kelly moneymaker corshow wolf katoitska
Alex Schwinn Andy mcgehi Jerry lambdin
rod D Martin AF Firefly Marcus arsner
why in hockey Spencer Lightfoot Marvin
Castle Captain said okmoon Yoon Winston
K would miss izet boogly Wiggly Maggie
pascowski the macquapo Gustav Swan
calling Dr Howard Dr Fine Dr Howard
Coppertone she went in spinning three
plates words about books podcast Jim
Stromberg words about books podcast and
Charles the first